[音楽]
今日はハード社長です今日は7月の初館馬崎の誕生日ですより鼻先が良いよ24たいと
いうことで待って屈強で誰の誕生日ので僕なりに彼に何かをしてあげたいと思ってそう
思って僕はちょっと海に来たんですけどもう彼は近くまで読んでいるので最高の
プレゼントをあげようと思います
しています
ガー入ってきたときは例えばせるございまーす
wh
24歳という
同い年ということで入ったかぁああ
20状態の抱負みたいなはれますか
[音楽]
謙虚雅紀に木炭ツールプレゼントを準備しましたまず老板ください冒頭つんでしたので
ふつう炭素ピっていったらこうなんかプレゼントだものとかそういうイメージがあるの
ですけども僕は今日は先に
形式をプレゼントしたい綺麗な景色を弾きにプレゼントしたいので俺もまだ
波売りたいなこれもまた観たことないんだけど
今日はいい
水平線まで行こうと思います子供の時にはなかったじゃん
だからどこまで行けるかんってああやったけどそれが今の24いい年になったこのおじ
さん何あればベトナム力だったらどこまで連れてる誓っているか
まんちゃん大虎じゃあ目指して頑張りましょうん
じゃあさっそく
大の大人が2人が本 bs 異名点滅したらどこまでできるのか
やっていきたいとおもいますみんな怖いけど
yeah それ行けてるそれに
toranoana
ran
amaran
あっはぁ re
もどっちゃってるよああ
2はん
はっはー
性的なん
wh
ban
amaran
ええええええ
car
then ぞフィギュア
goo
tan
ana
goo
can you do
taron の日記
ああああああ
い
えっ
ああああああ
くん
dare
me
tj
web ar
ええええええええええ
wh
ん
[音楽]
ああ気もするえっ
はよ
[音楽]
nan
だい
[音楽]
teame
car
ああっあった